فالعمليات العسكريه التي شنتها قوه
الاحتلال منذ تولي حكومه نتنياهو الحكم
اسفرت عن استشهاد 13 فلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس واعتقال نحو 190 غالبيتهم
في الضفه الغربيه فالثاني من يناير
الجاريه اندلعت مواجهات عنيفه خلال اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال بلده كفردان غرب مدينه جنين
واسفلت العمليه عن استشهاد شابين
فلسطينيين في الثالث من يناير اقتحم وزير
الامن القوميه الاسرائيلي اتمار بنك كثير
ومجموعه من المستوطنين باحات المسجد
الاقصى تحت حمايه الشرطه الاسرائيليه في
اليوم ذاته استشهد الطفل ادم عياد البالغ
من العمر 15 عاما اثر اصابته برصاصه في
الصدر خلال اقتحام قوه الاحتلال لمخيم
الدهيشه في مدينه بيت لحم في الرابع عشر
من يناير لاحقت قوه الاحتلال مركبه
فلسطينيه وقتلت شابين فلسطينيين في اعقاب
اقتحامها لبلده شبع جنوب جنيه واضمن
الاجراءات العقابيه التي بداها وزير الامن
القومي في حق الاسرى الفلسطينيين نقل 40
اسيرا من ذوي الاحكام العاليه من سجن
هيداريم شماله تل ابيب الى سجن نفحه في
صحراء النقب جنوبه اسرائيل